while news of the pirates approach first
reached grinderwick and southern iceland
at the end of june there were many
grandiose words and much fearless
boasting not in the least by the danish
authorities a defensive rampart was
built around the danish merchant houses
on the westmon islands and ships
prepared for defence
the danes boasted that the icelanders
would all flee at the first sign of
trouble
preparations stood like this until
people heard that the pirates had gone
away and that they no longer posed any
threat to the westmon islands
after that people became careless
despite some warnings that they had been
given and this went on until the 16th of
july
which was a monday
then people saw three ships early in the
morning off the south coast one of which
was very large
when the first ships were seen that
morning all the people were called to
the danish merchant houses for defence
and strongly prohibited from leaving
they stayed there all that day until
evening when night had come however the
people went away because the danes began
to say that they thought the three ships
must be part of the defensive force that
had been sent to protect iceland
then all the people went back to their
homes and laid aside their preparedness
and so these servants of satan the
father of all ungodliness
god their will
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
what is the key difference between
wyverns and dragons a their size
b the number of legs or c their manners
correct in british heraldry wyverns are
often depicted with two legs and so my
recommendation on magellan tv this week
is a great new documentary series called
myths and monsters 4k a six-part work
that explores the bizarre history behind
some of our greatest myths and legends
from troy to ragnarok it is maximum epic
and has some beautiful imagery and of
course magellan have more than 3000
other documentaries to check out too
it's a sort of netflix for documentaries
so click on the link in the description
for an exclusive month-long free trial
for voices of the past viewers
thanks
the next day when the had dropped the
evil pirates lowered overboard three
boats which they called sluffer and
which are quite large and very quickly
put 300 men into them and rushed ashore
there were english fishermen in these
boats who guided the pirates to an
unusual landing place where nobody in
living memory had ever before managed to
come ashore
the pirates landed so suddenly that the
people found it hard to escape them
they rushed with violent speed across
the island like hunting hounds howling
like wolves and the weak women and
children could not escape especially on
the farms above the lava because the
pirates had a shorter way there
only a few of the people who were
strongest or had nothing to carry or did
not pay attention to anyone else managed
to avoid capture
i with my weak group was quickly taken
some of my neighbours managed to escape
quickly into the caves or down the
cliffs some were able to gain their
freedom again but who exactly i cannot
tell
for i and my poor wife were amongst the
first to be captured we struggled for a
long time until we were beaten and
struck with the butts of their spears
and had to give in i've since wondered
that they did not kill us all with their
beatings i think most of those attacking
us were english
what follows i have heard from four men
who were left behind when the pirates
departed they saw the evil pirates first
divide themselves into three groups
the group which was the biggest perhaps
150 strong carried three red banners
they went straight to the danish
merchant houses and immediately attacked
this was easy for them because the danes
had all fled half an hour earlier the
other two pirate groups quartered the
island capturing people wherever they
found them young and old women and men
in infants
the pirates captured people in their
houses on the mountain slopes in caves
and in holes and even in inaccessible
places where the icelandic folk could
not go except very carefully they killed
everybody who fought against them and
anybody who made the sign of the cross
were named the name of jesus
the dead
lay
everywhere
four people were shot to death in caves
four others were lured from there and
deceived by the turkish pirates
the reverend john was killed down by the
seashore close to his home
at this time the wind turned to the east
so that the scoundrel pirates got all
they could wish
as the prophet says you let them free so
they should be slaughtered and saved
them for killing
one of the turkish ships which had never
reefed sail took advantage of the
changed wind to sail at once into the
harbour where it shot off three cannon
the lander kirkche church stood
in flames
on tuesday as those of us already
captured sat in the danish house where
we had been driven the evil pirates
gathered together everyone else whom
they had taken and in that crowd i saw
my children
it was by now midday the three houses
where we were kept could no longer
contain all the people so the pirates
ordered us to stand on the pavement in
front of the houses
where we were surrounded by these evil
men when i came out of the house and saw
their commander i went up to him with my
poor wife and we fell on our knees in
despair in front of him and his
undercapped in and begged for mercy
but our begging did no good when i saw
their headgear i knew that these pirates
were turkish then all those taken
prisoners who were considered to be in
acceptable condition were transferred to
the pirates ship in two ten-owed boats
the icelanders were ordered to row
against a sharp easterly wind and they
were beaten and flogged with ropes
then we were forced onto the pirate's
biggest ship which had lain there at
anchor in the deepest part of the
harbour and never come near shore when
the pirates on that ship saw us climb
miserably aboard they rejoiced
a short time thereafter i was called to
the stern of the ship and commanded by
the pirate captain to sit down
at once two of the turks took my hands
and bound them tightly together while
others bound my feet
the captain then beat me striking and
kicking me along my back while i
screamed helplessly with the pain of it
i do not know how many blows he gave me
but he beat me as hard as he could until
i was too hoarse to scream any longer
then a man was brought forward who spoke
german he asked me if i knew about any
money that might be anywhere i said
forcefully that i knew of none and
wanted only that they beat me to death
quickly and have done
they left me alone then raised me up and
ordered me back to the bow of the ship
i could hardly stand or walk so badly
they had hurt me
my fellow icelanders had compassion for
my poor plight
but the evil pirates
just laughed
[Music]
for the whole of the next day the evil
pirates were continually coming and
going from the ship and on each trip
they came back with more wretched people
as prisoners but so that you honest
reader should know the truth i must say
that after the people came aboard the
ship at this time the pirates did not
annoy anyone except me but behaved well
towards them all and were even kind to
the children though this does not make
the story any happier
now it may happen that you would like to
know what these vile pirates look like
both in personal appearance and in dress
truly speaking
they are like other peoples different in
size and look some small some large some
black
some are not of turkish origin at all
but are christian people of other
countries such as
england germany or denmark or norway
the turks all have black hair and they
shave their heads and their beards
except on the upper lip
in truth
they are not very wicked looking people
rather they are quiet and well tempered
in their manner
if it is possible to describe them like
that
but the ones who have been christians
and have forsaken their religion
although they dress like the turks are
by far the worst of people and cruelly
brutal to christians
it was they who bound those taken
captive and wounded and killed people
the most accurate reckoning of the
number of icelandic people killed is 34.
there were 242 people captured in all
and by wednesday evening all were aboard
the turkish ships
when the poor icelandic people saw their
homeland disappearing behind them there
was much wailing and lamentation all
that first day
when finally the wailing diminished they
tried to comfort each other and the
plight with god's words women as well as
men both young and old
on the 30th of july my poor wife gave
birth after the proper time to a boy
child who was named after the blessed
reverend john i myself baptized the
child as if i were back on land but my
heart was filled with grief
when the evil pirates heard that a child
had been born and heard the child crying
they gathered in a crowd
two of them gave old shirts to wrap the
child in on that voyage there was one of
the pirates on our ship who washed
himself normally every day in water he
was also washed by others during the
month that we were travelling
the honest woman margret said that this
pirate had killed her husband
all this washing could not make him
clean
during our month of travel two or three
old women died who had been taken
captive in east iceland their bodies
were wrapped in old sail cloth and they
were quickly tossed overboard
on the 16th or 17th of august we came to
algiers the place where our captors
lived straight after the anchor it hit
bottom the captured people were put on
land in a great hurry and our sufferings
which god alone can redress
continued
when the poor icelandic people were put
on land such a huge crowd gathered that
i think it was impossible to count their
number
they did not come for any cruel purpose
but only to look at the poor captives
we icelanders were separated from each
other friend from friend children from
their parents and driven through the
streets from one house to another to the
marketplace where we were put up for
auction as if we were sheep or cattle
the people who'd been captured in east
iceland were the first offered for sale
the men being kept separate in some
houses the women in other houses
this went on until the 28th of august by
which time most of the east iceland
people were sold
we poor westman islands people were
taken to the marketplace in groups each
of 30. the turks guarded each group in
front and behind and counted heads at
each street corner because the
inhabitants of that place will steal
such captive people if they get the
chance
when we came to the marketplace we were
placed in a circle and everyone's hand
and face were inspected
then the king chose from this group
those whom he wanted every eighth as i
mentioned earlier his first choice
amongst the boys was my own poor son
11 years old whom i will never forget as
long as i live because of the depth of
his understanding and knowledge
when he was taken from me i asked him in
god's name not to forsake his faith
he said with great grief
i will not my father they can treat my
body as they will but my soul i shall
keep for my good god
[Music]
i and my wife and our two young children
a one-year-old and a one month old were
taken from that place up to the king's
hall and there we sat with the children
in our arms for two hours
from there we were then taken to the
king's prison where we spent that night
from that time on i do not know what
became of the rest of the icelandic
people
i would like to comfort and strengthen
the people with my words
but i cannot and whether i speak of such
things or not
my suffering does not lessen
whatever happens
we are the lords
to tell the truth we captives were given
ample food evenings and mornings we had
bread warm from the oven and good
porridge groats with fat put into it
nothing else was given us to drink other
than lukewarm
brackish water
what i saw in this place of evil people
is difficult for me to describe because
i was so disoriented and grief-stricken
at that time the first thing that we
captives met on the streets when we came
ashore were the donkeys heavily laden
these animals are small by our standards
no bigger than a two-year-old mare but
they are very strong for carrying things
in that town i also saw five camels
which are strong and enormous
i saw a dwarf man and also a dwarf woman
because they are so common in that town
he looked to me to be less than two l's
tall and she one and a half l's tall
he had a short trunk and was long legged
with long arms reaching almost down to
his knees
he was black as pitch with a big head
she was astonishingly fat with short fat
legs and a long trunk
the town itself is built upon the slope
of a mountain it is narrower near the
upper end at the top of the mountain
seen from a distance it seems to be
about a mile wide
many there are who look fair and
embellish themselves in order to better
carry through their evil business
as david says
whatever happens we are the lords
[Music]
during the time that we three icelanders
were in our house yes but christiansen
and i felt unwell but john became truly
sick
then my honest wife was allowed to visit
me but not stay there very long oh lord
our transgressions deserve punishment
but you help for your name's sake
during that time i was barefoot and had
no shoes then god awakened one frenchman
who had been there for a long time the
man gave me new shoes and some aqua
vitae when i was sick
and then that same man told me many
icelandic people were lying sick and
dying all around the town which did not
make us happy he also told me that in
the christian cemetery there were
already 31 people buried
the icelanders could not endure the
terrible heat of that place the same
frenchman also told me that a girl who
had been my servant who was very
good-looking had been sold
first for 700
but then a rich man came from jerusalem
38 miles to the northeast and paid a
thousand for her and took her back with
him to jerusalem where he gave her to a
christian man in that place christian
men cannot have intercourse with turkish
women nor turkish men with christian
women otherwise they lose their lives
about such things i do not need to write
further except to say that i witness
these things
and that they are truth
[Music]
on the 20th day of september i was taken
from the house where i was imprisoned by
four men and brought to the street where
the house containing my wife and babies
was located
i begged with all humbleness and prayer
of the men who had fetched me that i
might be allowed to say goodbye to my
wife and the children who were with her
all of whom were deadly sick
i was hardly allowed ten words with them
however and then my captors callously
pulled me away
oh distress on distress
after this painful meeting with my
family i was taken to the street where
the official who was to issue me a safe
conduct lived
this safe conduct written in many
different languages i was to give to any
turkish pirates who might capture a ship
on which i was a passenger the document
explained that i should neither be
killed nor interfered with because i was
acting as a messenger i still have this
document and have shown it to several
people including the archbishop of
copenhagen
in order to receive this safe conduct i
had to kiss the pirates hands again
and that same day
i was put aboard an italian ship
on this voyage i suffered great hardship
and distress and at one point for lack
of proper food and water i was reduced
to drinking water which a lion a bear an
ostrich and some monkeys and poultry had
drunk from and befouled
even so i was glad so thirsty was i
we came in sight of iceland on the 4th
of july
and on the 6th to the westman islands
when i came there the poor people
received me as if i had been their own
best friend returning again from death
some of these honest men and women
proved themselves to be kindly and
generous
my poor daughter took me in and cared
for me the seventh day of that month i
went to the mainland and there met my
beloved neighbours relatives and good
friends who received me with complete
joy and did everything for me that they
could
so much that i cannot write it all
all the people were very kind and
generous towards me god opens the hearts
of men and showers mercy upon those who
most need it
all good gifts come from our father in
heaven above
[Music]
you